bonsoir les infirmières ce n'est pas
fini une nouvelle fois elle était dans
la rue à l'appel de la coordination à
laquelle la cgt s'est jointe elle
n'accepte toujours pas les accords
signés par les syndicats et parle de
nouveau de grève avant de retrouver
emilie race ou le ministère de la santé
ou à 21h claude evin recevait les
représentants de la coordination le fil
de cette journée avec eric tréguier
c'est la rechute les infirmières ont
décidé de ne pas se contenter d accord
négocié par les syndicats et le
ministère aujourd'hui au total plus de
soixante mille personnes dans la rue
dont les aides soignants et les agents
hospitaliers avec en fin de cortège
henri krasucki est la cgt au programme
revalorisation des salaires effectifs et
formation après l'abrogation du décret
barzakh le tout assorti d'un échéancier
dix jours après la fin de la grève dans
les hôpitaux et après le soutien apporté
aux infirmières par les acteurs de
cinéma la mobilisation est toujours
aussi forte
il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'infirmières de
la province qui sont montés aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'au niveau des hôpitaux de
la région parisienne la mobilisation
s'est faite aussi
réenclenché un processus de grève comme
ça en plein milieu de semaine avec tout
ce que ça veut dire d'obligations au
niveau des malades au niveau des
naissances est difficile
et rêvait de la coordination nationale
des ingénieurs sont en ce moment même
reçue par trop de vin ici au quatrième
étage du ministère de la santé par deux
fois cet après midi il avait refusé de
rencontrer son directeur était mené le
débat et en haute-loire sénat pour
défendre son projet contre le sida
la famille a su rester mobiliser une
grande partie de la journée devant le
ministère claude evin a
vraisemblablement voulu faire un geste
de bonne volonté en les recevant ce soir
mais la presse que lançait cette heure
ci il n'ira pas plus loin les
infirmières devraient en sortir
dubrule avec le devin on s'attend donc à
ce qu'elles poursuivent leur mouvement
de grève jusqu'à dimanche prochain
accord signé rien n'est réglé crier tel
dans la rue tout à l'heure peut-être
mais après six semaines de mouvement la
mobilisation risque d'être de plus en
plus difficile à faire